for the first time this morning we're
hearing from someone who worked inside
one of the facilities caring for
undocumented children separated from
their parents we showed you this video
on Wednesday from inside the Cayuga
centers right here in New York groups of
children can be seen in what looked like
classrooms at one point a little girl
starts to cry because she cannot speak
to her mom these videos were provided to
CBS News by attorney Michael avenatti
they were recorded by a former employee
of Cayuga centers who quit because of
what she calls injustice the facility is
not commented on her allegations and the
circumstances of her departure in a
statement to CBS News KOCO sender says
this its staff members go far beyond the
requirements of their jobs and ensuring
the safety and comfort of all
unaccompanied children referred to their
program the mill abayas is her name
she's a former Cayuga senator's employee
who recorded the videos she's joined now
with her lawyer Michael avenatti for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning
welcome to you both to the table Camila
I want to start with you what did you
see that made you think I got to pull
out my phone and record this I think
that what made me pull out a phone was
knowing that these kids were getting
psychologically it was affecting them
tremendously and physically as well what
what did you see that made you know they
were being affected psychological I me
by me asking them do you want to speak
to your clinician and case manager I saw
that the kids will start automatically
crying because they didn't have the
opportunity to speak to their parents
that I have been in detention centers
for example I had a minor that didn't
speak to his mom for a month and a half
because he didn't know his situation we
keep hearing that these kids are allowed
to have contact and communicate with
their parents they do but there's not
enough phones in the company to make
these phone calls and yet Pamela your
former employer says that the children
they're fed nutritious food provided
essentials such as clothing and
toiletries and are visited by doctors as
well so what did you see that bothered
you what bothered me was that for
example a lot of these kids through the
medical department they were taking very
very long time to get seen
[Music]
also the psychological trauma that was
going on a lot of the kids weren't being
seen right away you know Michael when we
spoke on Wednesday you told me that in
one of the videos that we saw of a
little boy named Leo his mother Lourdes
had been deported back to Guatemala
Pamela do the kids understand that their
parents in some cases may be thousands
of miles away from where they are a lot
of them they don't even understand
because if you see in the in the video
of Jessica a dynamic stir first about
where her mother is she said in the
States so she thought her mom was still
in the in in the States but she has no
idea she it took her a while to figure
out yes it's in Virginia but a lot of
these kids they have no idea where their
parents are in over 80% of the cases
that I'm involved in and I represent
over 60 mothers you know for 80% of
those cases the parents don't know where
the children are and the children don't
know where the parents are the
government has effectively stolen these
children from these parents and have
refused to tell the parents where
they're at because in most cases they
don't know where they're at I mean this
is a travesty
that these parents have been separated
from their children and vice versa and
there does not appear to be a will to
reunite these children with their
parents we keep hearing though Michael
that the reunification process is
underway that the that the kids are
being allowed to communicate with their
parents and vice versa
that's not your experience that's just
not true Gail I have countless parents
that I'm representing mothers that don't
know where their children are want to
communicate with their children are not
able to communicate with their children
and I see nothing to indicate that
there's any concentrated effort to
reunite these kids with their parents
how complicated is this it's not that
complicated if there's a will to reunite
these kids well that what you're saying
too familiar that there's no really is
there a system to figure out how to get
the children and their parents back
together that you could see well the
system that I know about is that they
have this system where it's called like
a sponsor where they find a sponsor for
the child but at the end of the day
that's not who you came with to the
United States you didn't come with you
came with your family so that's how you
that's who you
should be with not a regular sponsor
that they probably don't even know and I
don't think that we should be handing in
our kids to any stranger you know I
think that is important for these kids
to stay here one of the things we keep
hearing though Michael is that you know
drug dealers and gang members or in some
cases using these children to get into
the country or that they are slipping
through the country themselves by with
these kids what is your experience with
that Gail there may be an isolated
incident here or there but that's a
bunch of nonsense and it's designed by
the President and some of his supporters
to create this boogeyman in a closet and
scare people these mothers and fathers
have come to the United States in an
effort to to pursue the American dream
and to pursue a better life for
themselves and their children these are
thugs or not drug dealers they're not
using kids as shields it's an absolute
absurdity yeah were you saying that gang
members and drug dealers coming in no
not at all is the opposite people are
running away from the gangs they're not
there there's no gangs coming in and if
you see the rates they're actually lower
you knew you could lose your job by
doing this yeah but you knew you could
lose your job yes I knew that but I
think that it's very important for this
to come out because I noticed that
nobody was doing anything and I thought
that by me actually coming out and
showing my face will give the courage to
other people to actually do the same
because I think that right now is not or
never this is the time to reunite these
families and this is what needs to
happen right now in Michael avenatti we
know you would store me down he was
lawyer now it's like now Michael
avenatti is involved in this case well
Gail I'd say about that I've been
fighting against injustice for 18 years
and I'm gonna continue to do so and it
just so happens that this president is
constantly on the other side of the law
and outside the bounds of the law and if
I see something that bothers me that I
think people need support and assistance
I'm gonna provide it how do you reach
out to him he reach out to you know I
reached out to him I did my own personal
research within the company also about
avenatti and I was that gave to me the
trust that I could trust on him so you
would who did did he ask you to tape
no no everything happened afterwards me
doing my research and looking for
somebody that I could trust all right
Miller we thank you Mike
thank you for coming today okay both and
very brave of you to do that
I hadn't seen what was happening in
those facilities thank very courageous
we don't get to see you inside the
facilities I hope more people show up
thank you right